no notes no script what is this 2008
good morning Hank it's Tuesday I really
liked your keeping it real video so I
decided that I am also going to try to
keep it real today for starters by using
slang that was last popular before many
of our viewers were born also heads up I
got a little bit of a tiny chicken
disease so I'm coming to you today with
my husky voice I feel like I could
narrate a movie trailer right now like
in a world where a man has two children
who were essentially tiny carriers of
viruses so I can the last couple months
I had this amazing trip to Ethiopia
which was so wonderful I'm so grateful
for the opportunity to have gone there
and then I got meningitis which like
less grateful for but anyway at some
point in the last six months I started
to kind of have an existential crisis
like a young people often ask me what
they should do with their lives and I
always say that's a question wrongly put
because you don't just do one thing with
your life but that's kind of a cop-out
because the honest answer is I don't
know what to do with my own life let
alone what you should do with yours like
we are here on earth for a very brief
period of time and we have to use that
time wisely and I feel oh god it's
coming again oh I met both the coffee
and the existential crisis so yeah I
don't know here's what I do know I like
writing books and I like making stuff
for and with nerdfighters like the
experience of The Fault in Our Stars
movie was awesome thing but it was
mostly awesome because it felt like
Hollywood was making like a 15 million
dollar present for nerdfighteria I think
it's gonna be the same way with the
Paper Towns movie or even more so but
I'm really not that into Hollywood II
stuff I just don't know what I should be
doing should I write a new book I'm
trying to write a new book should I
spend tremendous amounts of time
ruminating about the terrible things
that people say about me and my work on
the Internet probably not but I do
should I be focused on metal floss or
crash course or the art assignment or
vlog brothers or the all-important AFC
wimbledon wimbly Wobblies and in trying
to do all of these things am i doing
none of them well yeah as you pointed
out in your video these are problems of
extreme extreme privilege and I am
grateful to have them but I want to
figure out how to be a good nerdfighter
and how to be part of a strong
nerdfighter community and before I get
to your survey which thank you for doing
that survey in many ways the community
is incredibly strong like we just raised
$300,000 for water organ Ethiopia that's
more money than was raised by the first
six
project for awesome is combined so I
don't want to be all doom and gloom
about this I just want to be honest
about the fact that like I am stressed
out right now and don't know what to do
like it speaks to my current overall
emotional well-being that when I saw the
results of the survey about what
nerdfighters want us to do and the first
thing that they chose was to spend more
time with our friends and family I began
to weep because I know I should spend
more time with my children I mean how
else am I going to get all of these
viruses except from them after friends
and family you guys wanted us to help
people understand current events which
is something that we haven't been doing
enough of lately Hank because it takes a
lot of work and we're doing a lot of
other things but that is good to know
that that is a priority for the
community and you want to raise money
and attention for charities around the
world that is a hugely important part of
our work becoming a more important part
I think so maybe we're good there then
crash course which we spend a lot of
time on so good by the way in the coming
month you might be seeing less of my
face on crash course but I will still be
working a lot on it but my favorite
result of this survey is that in dead
last is making viral videos that get
lots of views so the thing that like
metrics and business strategies would
tell you to do is literally the least
interesting thing to nerdfighteria which
is good because it is also not that
interesting to me you also wanted us to
do stuff like make more vlogbrothers
videos and focus on science education
which is great because it means that
your values and our values still line up
I do have one question though I'm not
going to set up a survey or anything
because I don't know how to do that but
like what would you like us to do less
of so I can write a book and hopefully
have more time to like be a nerdfighter
and try to build nerd fight astok stuff
within the community nerdfighteria thank
you again for helping to raise more than
three hundred thousand dollars for water
org which is going to permanently
transform the lives of more than ten
thousand people in Ethiopia and most of
all thank you for sticking with us in
helping us again and again and again to
find our way Hank I will see you on
Friday